[Music]
from this tiny Malaysian fishing village
from the cheesy public domain music to
the framing of the shots to the
self-important voiceover that's clear
survivor was going for a documentary
type field when it started and that does
its poorly these 16 Americans are
beginning the adventure of a lifetime
or if it's successful in the audience
likes them maybe one of the many
adventures of their lifetime because if
Survivor were a cow on Dirks dairy farm
it'd have these sourced eats in bovine
history from being milked so hard see
honey those are Americans they are
coming here to prove they can survive
somewhere other than a couch
can you imagine they have volunteered to
be marooned well if by volunteered you
mean picked after a casting process to
participate in a game show them sure
they volunteered in the same way
presidential candidates volunteered to
be President but at least that's the
only way politics and reality TV will
ever cross paths survival reality show
shows animals that the contestants won't
actually ever see because they are
sequestered on a small protected part of
the environment clichéd this person is
way too excited about pouring ocean
water from this canteen onto their face
and what the monkey doesn't get a name
clearly this is mr. burka fluffle and he
would completely win this show if only
he could understand the power of greed
oh the show has just incited mayhem into
the contestants hearts and it's the host
job to ignore the flailing people and
speak calmly to the camera as if this is
an everyday occurrence reality TV
teaching us to treat other people's
panic and emotional trauma as
entertainment right from the start don't
be my own is that similar to being
periwinkle because my Perry is winkled
recently and if that's a prerequisite
for competing for a million dollars I
demand my spot 39 days 16 people's the
16 contestants have been separated into
two tribes and the show will take the
next two minutes doing some good old
fashioned narration as Propst Jeffs
positions each and every castaway
complete with yearbook style photo
shoots get to the surviving already hard
to imagine that just four hours ago this
group met for the first time I feel like
reality TV script writers need to listen
and just how strong my imagination is
because I didn't have any trouble
imagining that at all
under the rules one tribe must visit
tribal council every three days with a
single purpose vote one of their own
members FBI and thus competitive reality
shows were launched this format is so
pure and exciting that I'm glad they'd
never tinker with it by introducing
hidden immunity idols surprise tribal
shake ups or extinction island gimmicks
glad that'll never happen
celebratory butt slaps he may be 72
years old in the next Navy SEAL but that
doesn't mean that this is his world yeah
because why I listen to someone who has
been trained to be a Navy SEAL reality
TV makes me miserable because humans are
annoying I'm used to being in a lab but
this is like outdoors 24/7 uh-huh and
when you signed up to be marooned on an
island did you think they'd helicopter
you to a posh resort with twinkle lights
and a butler you get what you get you
don't throw a fit Ramona I'm not gonna
sin that she doesn't actually have a
watch here because have your fun little
jokes and all but I am going to send
that her imaginary watch apparently only
tells her days on the island that's a
very specific watch that does not exist
[Music]
but first let's talk about how and why
you manage to perch yourself up in that
tree like a proboscis monkey the next
seven ejections 21 days we have to
function together or we fail not
functioning together at all for the
trained reality TV watcher you can hear
the producers simultaneously orgasming
in the background this [ __ ] is their
ratings gold and God and we must know
all bow down to our drama llama overlord
but I've got the million-dollar check
written already I mean I'm the winner
and it's that kind of cocky attitude
that makes people really hate your guts
well that insulting people not paying
your taxes and walking around nude what
others have made it clear it makes them
uncomfortable I mean if that's something
he ever does in the future look if you
think we survived this episode without
getting a few sins to dick a CH you
don't know us very well having said that
this is the moment that solidified
survivor is one of the best sociological
experiments of all time there's a reason
the show's been around for 40 seasons
and continues to pull good ratings
because watching humans interact and all
their strange beautiful humanity is
fascinating and it always will be things
that individuals do kind of get in the
way of the whole team explaining so for
example you know Shawn what do you think
I'm trying do you think the main point
of what I'm trying to say
actual footage of TV sends staff meeting
somehow makes it into Survivor survivor
tries to cash in on the early millenium
stop craze and fails miserably outdoor
toilets trail washes out all the trail
washes on washes and let me walk well at
least you're clear about what you're
looking for and you will be successful
too lost forever in the wild but you'll
find all sorts of any things that
resemble anything that's for sure we
could never do this but you know what
the thought crossed my mind yes we laugh
at the crazy idea of using strategy to
get ourselves further what is this a
game the naivete of this first group of
survivors is astounding we now interrupt
this reality show or a scene from The
Departed
stupid departed Rhett I don't even know
what MTV means yeah
good news Rudy neither does MTV
theory richard rigged this machete to
immediately dysfunction and possibly
take out his competitors eye or maybe
that was the production team just a
theory I'm sure nothing about this is
actually rigged who brings a ukulele to
deserted island and forgets a king
hairbrush Susan's over there chopping
off her hair while you're singing being
all lucky plucky so vie on an island
with an optimistic ukulele player just
made my list of nightmares oh I'll have
adorable pets to befriend on their own
oh god no
Joel woke up a rat was like in the ear -
Joel laugh at you and you chucked up the
ocean on your rat rod yesterday no he
didn't I mean the producers have
complete control of what I see and don't
see but still you're clearly an [ __ ]
for laughing at someone with rats coming
out of their ears who's this guy I swear
were only twenty minutes into this thing
and they're swapping out players right
dude says like three syllables this
entire episode no one will be seated
during the old man builds jungle fort by
himself with no help from any of his
lazy teammates portion of the program
he'd been out there you know all morning
long edging and trimming tree planks
Jesus where did this would even come
from I don't remember them having a
uniform bundles of wood tied to their
raft when they were marooned rather to
be be fine all of this and why aren't
you all praising him like the goddamn
hero he is I'm gonna keep working we are
you know when get off my lawn collided
with let's all get along someone was
going to end up condescendingly calling
someone else sweetheart I'm not kidding
if he would have called her it gaped
wretched [ __ ] from the depths of
Satan vial filled scrotum it would have
been less offensive than that so they're
just gonna spend their energy holding
the wood rubbing back and forth sweating
and moaning trying to get out friction
in that little crease to create some
sort of I'm sorry
what was I saying alright scene does not
contain a fire dance we made a lot of
smoke but no fire this is no no that
saying goes throughout their time on the
island I some exposition will baby pros
want everybody to touch this get a good
feel of this college freshmen this is
the immunity idol idol worship
that's like commandment number two men
doesn't get much more cine than that
[Music]
thank survivor for putting text on the
screen that confirms what I can already
see with my own two eyes how would I
ever be able to feel this incredible
manufactured intensity without it so
this confirms that it's a cult right if
this doesn't end with a sex ritual in a
bear suit I'm calling cult mannequins is
he down with the one that is known as
I'm from the g2 the hope that he'd never
done show misses a huge opportunity for
a DC top needle drop you know he's fat
but he's he's good rudy is the best one
thing survivor nailed right off the boat
was casting great personalities Rudy was
one of the best and will be missed it
all begins with a dangerous hike through
the jungle and by dangerous we mean they
had to occasionally step over tree
branches dear god save us all that is
far too many it's obviously a million
dollars big motivator they literally
pretended to put the money in front of
them like their heads up at the World
Series of Poker the origin of Survivor
is so full of cheesiness that you could
stir it in with some macaroni for a meal
for all our sakes I hope in future
seasons they learn to cut some of that
cheese apparently Sue's building out
sauna when there's no one by that name
on the tribe the very first vote in
Survivor history pours the misspelled
name salt on the torch sniffing wounds
and the sin is for the death of
phonetics they see of call subtle
reasons
not sure exactly what they are well glad
the producers allowed us in on that
blistering insight from the mastermind
stunning stuff maybe sale he doesn't
know how to start fire and he just
criticizes everything
yeah but the producers failed to show me
that part so I find your truth and valid
try the spoken it's one of the most
iconic lines in television history it
remains the heart and soul of survivor
two full decades later and it's wrong
the tribe wrote those names for their
official votes so it should be the tribe
has written and for anyone who thinks
that's semantics and purposely pedantic
and short-sighted first welcome to the
channel and second the sins have spoken
oh that's million ants I can't see the
answer over here I just assumed that was
a turd man
wiggly turd man but I've got the million
dollar check written already I mean I'm
the winner you're not wrong Walter
you're just an [ __ ] we have to cross
the stream so you go across one stream
two streams three streams excuse me a
gun
you said crossing the streams was bad
[Applause]
[Music]
legend top the Hidden Temple